[Music]
zombies they're hot right now
oh yeah the walking dead the talking
dead fear the walking dead be the
walking dead walking dead top chef
walking dead real-world World War Z its
prequel world worldwide its sequel World
War a zombies are everywhere
that's where Rutgers st. Lawrence come
to see Rucker is a pure warrior of the
mind tortured eyes radiates compassion
whilst wisdom dances from this everyman
lips he has seen and said it all most
people in this new world have had to
become handy with a weapon to survive
but not Rutger oh no he was born with a
weapon his words and when I seed whoever
it may be a he or a she but probably she
then I will be the one that pollinates
thee like the bee he does the tree and
then finally you and I will see the word
that needs no rhyme
and with every zombies mind he blows to
pieces he brings back another piece of
humanity in the hopes of world peace
also he's a black guy we're very excited
about this and we'll call you when we're
ready to make an offer you keep that I
got plenty